[Musique]
en janvier station suivie
post-opératoire c'était revenu sur les
deux poumons et au genou là c'était
double récidive à partir de là on savait
qu'il y avait plus rien à faire
Caroline Marcoux ne se connaissent pas
mais il y a deux ans à quelques mois
d'intervalles ils ont traversé la même
épreuve leur fils tous deux âgés de 17
ans et atteint d'un cancer des os sont
des CD
aujourd'hui on leur mémoire il mène des
combats bien différents Caroline milite
pour que les mineurs aient accès à
l'aide médicale à mourir quand il s'est
fait dire qu'il y avait pas droit à
l'aide médicale à mourir puis qui me
demandait de faire quelque chose j'ai
promis je te promets je vais faire tout
ce que je peux pour que les choses
changent que les autres enfants comme
toi et pas à attendre la mort Mike lui
fait partie d'une organisation qui s'y
oppose
on a souvent tendance à penser à manger
un enfant qui marche c'est horrible et
c'est Gabriel Brodeur et pédiatre en
soin palliatif au centre mère-enfants de
Québec bien qu'elle juge arbitraire
l'âge de 18 ans pour avoir accès à
l'aide médicale à mourir on sait que ça
va toucher particulièrement les jeunes
qui ont une maladie chronique qui sont
atteintes d'une maladie significative
qui ont ce vécu expérientiel qui leur
permettent probablement décider pour
eux-mêmes de manière même plus
surprenante que certains adultes qui
sont en santé elles croient que les
critères d'accès doivent être différents
entre un adulte et un mineur ça doit
nécessiter des mesures de sauvegarde qui
vont être différentes de l'adulte vous
nommez la fin de vie pour moi je crois
que ça doit demeurer vraiment essentiel
comme critère d'accès convaincu c'est un
débat qui mérite d'être fait pour
Jean-François Leroux avocat conseil pour
l'association mourir dans la dignité le
critère de l'âge ne tient pas la route
devant les tribunaux à tous les jours en
ce moment au Québec des mineurs de 14
ans et plus peuvent décider par
eux-mêmes de cesser soin qui sont
nécessaires au maintien à la vie et les
médecins doivent de toute façon procéder
à cette évaluation là de l'aptitude donc
c'est peut-être plus un mirage que ça
peut être une difficulté en soi
Jean-François Leroux accepterait sans
hésiter de défendre la cause d'un mineur
voulant avoir accès à l'aide médicale à
mourir Gabriel Brodeur elle se demande
comment elle réagirait si on de ces
jeunes patients réclamaient ce soin ça
désire de les accompagner jusqu'au bout
certainement va me faire me questionner
probablement positivement pour leur
permettre dans la compassion d'avoir
accès aux soins auxquels on droit et je
m'imagine pas appeler un collègue qui
connaissent pas par exemple si
j'aimerais ça probablement les
accompagner jusqu'au bout avec ce soin
là
Max se souvient de ce vendredi matin ou
son fils est entré à l'unité des soins
palliatifs de l'Hôpital pour enfants
devant couverts
[Musique]
toujours là Marcus a partagé un tout
dernier moment avec ses amis
[Musique]
Caroline aurait souhaité que son fils
lui puisse choisir
quand est-ce ça va arriver puis
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire finalement
pour accélérer des fois il m'appelait il
me laissait des messages ma maman quand
est-ce qu'on le sait c'est quand la mort
quand est-ce qu'on sait que c'est là ça
va être là puis il y avait peur d'être
tout seul aussi s'il y avait pu avoir
l'aide médicale choisir le moment
choisir avec qui était aussi c'est quand
tu es parti on a toute la famille était
pas là Mike ne s'en cache pas ses
croyances sont au centre de son combat
pour Marcus
pour Caroline ce qui donne un sens à la
mort de Charles c'est de se battre pour
donner à d'autres le droit de choisir
[Musique]